so that's pretty cool Hey look at that
the Fibonacci sequence has given us five
just by comparing successive terms
that's pretty amazing right okay down
here's what's going to happen though I'm
about to disappoint you because I said
that's pretty amazing yeah actually it's
not so amazing
okay watch what's going to happen I'm
going to look at another sequence now
I'm going to start in a similar way so
what I encourage you to do is to copy
out select these two columns here so I'm
going to select you can use your cursor
or you can just go to shift and then
move your cursor keys to surround them
I'm gonna copy that and we're just going
to go bless you into this space over
here and I'm going to paste it okay my
my columns will need to be adjusted a
little bit so that they're good with to
show you the numbers okay so I'm gonna
call this next sequence mr. Woo's
sequence okay and the reason why will
become clear in a second right ie
remember we need the Fibonacci sequence
what we did was we started with these
two numbers they're really important so
I'm gonna highlight them just so you can
see them so let's make the book read
shall we okay I hope you can see that so
those two numbers it kind of like the
seeds for the rest of the sequence once
you know those numbers the rest of the
sequence just kind of unfurls it just
follows the rules what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna take a different pair of
numbers in my C right and the pair of
numbers I'm gonna take is a pair of
numbers that I really like which is 19
and 9 because my birthday all right so
I've started with two completely
different numbers but otherwise I follow
the same rule to generate these the rest
of the sequence alright so if you've got
the same notice that I've got Fusina now
I've got 19 and 9 now in fact what you
can do if you want to blow your my deal
I mean war or disappoint yourself a bit
warmer instead of 19 and 9 you know what
just pick your own numbers maybe you
want to put your own birth
stay in there okay so I've got 19 and 9
maybe you're gonna have like the 5th of
August so that you'd be five and eight
okay
whatever two numbers you put in there
you'll have a different sequence so now
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
generate this third comp again that
ratio column okay so what I'm gonna do
is I'm just going to take that top one
there that was where I put my first
ratio calculation in and I'm gonna paste
it in the corresponding spot in my
sequence okay
I'll be visible to be a bit wider as
well okay and so you can paste it into
the corresponding spot like your
sequence now I've got zero point four
seven three six eight four that's
because that's the ratio between nine
and nineteen nine smaller that's why the
ratio is less than one so far so good
your ratio might be bigger depending on
what your birth date is okay now I'm
gonna take that and I'm just gonna paste
it let's see what happens as my sequence
progresses now your ratios or to be
slightly different to mine but if you go
far enough something interesting will
happen it's interesting or disappointing
depending on your point of view I'm
gonna make my own even a little bit
wider than that
okay what's happened well on my sequence
my ratios started for wacky and weird
but then wait a second I'm still
approaching fine and so should you be
whatever numbers you put at the top
right look if you got two computers with
me the two people on your left look over
at your friends they'll have a different
birthday I heard okay we all have two
birthdays different ratios but we all
converge we all converge on fire right
so in fact it doesn't look like the
Fibonacci sequence is so special after
all if you build it with the same rule
you always end up at fire no matter
where you start but I said I was going
to amaze you with the Fibonacci sequence
I said I was going to disappoint you by
showing actually it's not so unique
after all now I'm gonna blow your little
mind by showing you actually there is
one of these sequences that is more
special than any of the rest okay so
this time let's go again take your
Fibonacci sequence go down the bottom
copy it right and go over to the right
it inside paste it in you should have an
exact copy of the Fibonacci sequence
again but this time when we look at
those seed numbers this time we're all
going to put the same one in these
secrets is not called the Fibonacci
sequence it's called the Lucas sequence
named after a manager named Lucas
unsurprisingly okay now he made the most
miniscule of changes right I should just
quickly gasp is anyone's birthday the
second of January
anyone know okay well we're just going
to imagine that Lucas's birthday is the
2nd of January okay so if he were to
make his birthday sequence it would be
two and one and then you can enter yeah
before I go any further I'm just gonna
and you should copy that in as well I'm
just gonna know that two and one like
even though they're the seat numbers if
I change their order to make it one and
two I get a different sequence in fact
have a look at this what sequence is
this
this is the name Adachi sequence again
why is this a Fibonacci sequence we
started a different pair of numbers
didn't we
why did we get the same sequence back
look back at your Fibonacci sequence if
you have to what I get it yeah very good
one and two one or two they are still
part of the Fibonacci sequence it's just
the next terms
I just don't start beginning I've son
further it so for example if my scene
numbers were five and eight right five
and eight let's go back over here then
you will expect I get further along in
the Fibonacci sequence but it's still
the Fibonacci sequence so I come back
what I really want is not one or two but
two and one okay now if you look at this
and I do my ratio comparison again okay
let me make this a bit wider if I do my
ratio comparison again like we saw
before I'm going to approach fine no big
deal they are all approached by right so
that's no surprise but this time I'm
going to do something a little bit
different okay a little bit different
and I learned to lead out this column
because actually not that important to
me I let it go to this um this cell here
and you're gonna need that fine number
again so if you can't see it nearby like
I can't because mine is too large my
spreadsheets to logic what should a copy
it said it's somewhere nearby
so that you can access them I want you
to go down to the zero one two Lucas
number number two okay
I'm caught edge corresponding to that in
column okay so this is Lucas number two
okay Lucas no bar number 2 star
calculation equals now what we're going
to do is I'm going to take fine and I'm
going to raise it to a power right by to
the power of whatever
Lucas number I'm up to the second or the
third on the fourth or the fifth right
now you might notice looking at your
keyboard again you don't have a power
button so we're going to use this symbol
which is above the six it's a it's
called a hat because it
fine that looks like a hat okay so we're
going to go hat which means ^ and I want
you to go and click on the corresponding
that which Lucas number am i up to right
which is two so please no it's not ways
the Lucas no but it's which Lucas number
okay so I don't mean three I mean - and
I hit enter hold on a second I've got
too many decimal points here so I need
to okay so I've got a number which seems
a bit random
that would be unsurprising because pies
are missing them up so fighters some
power also be a missing number but I'm
going to try and continue this pattern
right now before you continue it I want
you to go back to this cell right it
should say much this is a very simple
feature line and I want you to change
something sirits is um I've got j:1 okay
yours might be somewhere else depending
on where fire is in your spreadsheet
okay you might have it on a - who has it
on a - well be one sorry it's a big one
that's better yet big one okay so if
your says be one day that's fine I want
you to put a dollar sign between the B
and the one dollar sign okay I'll
explain what the dollar sign does in a
minute I'm just going to get a name
diffident you're not mushroom they've
changed okay but now I can copy that
formula can you see two point six one
eight have you guys got that yeah
oh and copy that and I'm gonna paste it
below and then I'm gonna paste it below
again and again and again and I'm gonna
keep going all the way down to the end
of my list what do you notice what if I
go on this series of numbers I've just
developed which is fine fine cute fine a
pound for pound the power of 5 5 to the
6 five of the seven no no yes that's
fine that's fine to the 7 5 the 8 and so
on what are they giving me
these are giving me the Lukas numbers
you see that all I need to do is
approximate let me make it obvious for
you okay if you go to this sub this
called that we just created okay and
let's reduce the number of decimal
places that we've got so it's the icon
next to increased number of decimal
places so let's decrease whoops so I'm
just going to do one right if you
decrease it so that you've got no more
no more decimal places you're just
rounding on okay you can see it always
rounds off to the corresponding Lukas
number exactly all the way down look at
this look at this guy right in fact the
further we go along the more exact you
get fire the power of whatever will give
you look at that look at this one this
is equal to the Lukas number to the
fifth decimal place right that's
astonishing
the Fibonacci sequence is not is not
magical because it purchase fire it's
just like every other series because in
fridge is fine but the Lukas sequence
that's incredible look at that
corresponds and in fact if you go down
let's just copy this any further
these numbers are 2d so you start so you
start to run out of decimal places but
it continues the pattern continues and
if anything the pattern gets even closer